[Music]
dah dah you were terrifying and Finding
Nemo but you make a hilarious Halloween
costume please stop banging on the fish
tank and shaking the bag and go
trick-or-treating already the fish will
thank you just be careful not to get too
much candy stuck in your mouth gear or
you'll be back in the dentist's chair
and we all know what happened the last
time you were there
Darla is not the only epic movie
character who makes an awesome Halloween
costume with Halloween right around the
corner you don't want to miss these easy
to make costumes of your favorite
characters
the last one on our list is an absolute
scream here are 10 movie and TV
characters that make the best Halloween
costumes Moaning Myrtle Moaning Myrtle
is one of the most dramatic characters
in Harry Potter she's also one of the
biggest trouble makers we all know
Moaning Myrtle as The Crying ghost who
haunts the girls bathroom in Hogwarts
like many characters in Harry Potter she
has a dark and difficult history but
that doesn't mean we can't have a little
fun dressing up as her this clever
costume of Moaning Myrtle comes with a
toilet seat and a teardrop on her cheek
dr. Alex I
everyone knows dr. Alexi as the humorous
Russian scientists from stranger things
he provided some much-needed relief from
the tension created by the enormous mind
flyer
we all loved his character so why not
dress like him for Halloween check out
Instagram user Red River Trooper his
costume looks easy to put together all
you need is a white button-up shirt
glasses khaki pants tan cuffs and a
roadrunner stuffed toy don't forget the
most important prop we're talking about
the cherry Slurpee of course bonus
points if you know how to speak a
Russian Neytiri
Neytiri was a perfect combination of a
fierce warrior and a compassionate
leader in the movie Avatar if you want
to impress your friends at the Halloween
party this is definitely the costume
that will turn heads
don't let the intricate makeup
intimidate you me you who makeup on
Instagram gives an up-close look at her
makeup so you can copy if you
closely you'll see how she applied her
cosplay makeup just follow her lead and
pretty soon you'll look like our
favorite Navi princess
Lady Bird dressing up as Christine from
Lady Bird is so easy to pull off you
won't even need to visit a costume shop
all you need is a white button-down
shirt a black vest and a school uniform
skirt her backpack is optional but you
can't forget the most important element
the hot pink cast on her arm you'll
probably want some red hair spray or
hair dye to walk around trying to find
yourself while being mad at your mom and
you'll have totally nailed this
character I'm sorry I know I can lie and
not be a good person Mary Poppins
Instagram user look-alikes and
characters nailed this costume you can't
go wrong when dressing up as the world's
favorite English nanny you can easily
pull off this Mary Poppins look with a
quick trip to the thrift store just find
a long coat a hat with a bird or some
flowers on it a red bow tie white gloves
red lipstick and then neatly tuck your
hair into a twisted bun bonus points if
you can buy an umbrella with a parrot on
the handle then all you have to do is
sing and dance the night away Darla one
of the funniest Halloween costumes we've
come across is Darla from Finding Nemo
Instagram user Lucy B Fink did a great
job on this one this look is easy to
pull off and it will get lots of
attention just find the purple shirt and
print out the same rock and roll girl
logo from the movie then pen it on the
front of your shirt shape some head gear
out of aluminum foil put your hair in
pigtails and don't forget to include a
little orange fish toy inside a plastic
bag of water freak your friends out by
shaking the bag can you introduce me as
Joker
the Joker this costume is easier to pull
off than you might think
thank goodness for thrift stores you can
probably find the red suit like this one
from the Instagram user jerky derby then
paint some clown makeup on your face
have fun with your makeup and play with
a symmetry make the blue makeup under
your right eye longer than the left then
practice the maniacal laugh and you've
got it down pat beetlejuice it's hard to
think of Halloween without picturing Tim
Burton at his classic spooky comedy
Beetlejuice this character is so fun to
dress up as all you need is a crazy fun
wig spooky makeup and a black-and-white
striped suit
check out this look from Instagram user
arty by mass for inspiration she was
able to take a male character and FEM it
up we are loving those green eyebrows
that exactly like the original movie
character but it totally works
Effie Trinket Effie Trinket had the most
fabulous outfits on the Hunger Games the
cool thing about this costume is you can
get as creative as you want the only
limit is your imagination
just remember to include a colorful wig
a hat and some fabulous makeup details
Effie is all about showing off so the
bolder the better we love this costume
from Instagram user the jela beef
Pennywise and now it's time for the
scariest Halloween costume on this list
for this terrifying costume you'll need
a bald cap an orange wig white paint red
lipstick black eyeshadow and a puffy
white clown costume you can make one on
your own with a white t-shirt and pants
and the white tutu for the neck piece
but whatever you do don't forget your
red balloon which costume was your
favorite tell us in the comments thanks
for watching the things don't forget to
subscribe to our channel to be the first
to see our latest videos and click the
thumbs up button while you're at it see
you next time
[Music]